this is the theme the bismillah al
hamdulillah Salam alaikum peace be with
you welcome to the D show thank you for
tuning in I'm Eddie your host and we got
back in the studio with us today dr.
Lawrence Brown let me tell you a little
bit about dr. Lawrence Brown he is a
doctor by profession former US Air Force
Major some would say he's a Christian
scholar he's got some knowledge of the
Bible some knowledge of Christianity he
went from being an atheist tried very
hard to be a Christian didn't fit it
didn't work and he became a Muslim he
consciously chose to submit not to a man
to one but the creator of man and woman
to one God and he still fall into
teachings of Jesus how is that we're
going to be talking about this on this
week's show so don't go nowhere right
back this is the this is the thing is
the thing
this is the this is the Salam alaikum
peace be with you dr. Brown how are you
well it is my life you will go to
Captain now what you say you said
something in Arabic what's going on here
can you translate it for english for our
not yet muslim audience we will come
back to this later in the show i expect
inshallah ok I'm gonna hold you to that
ok you have a TI menachem waterfront
hola hey Roberto got to peace be upon
you what often to LA he and the drama
the mercy of Allah Allah baba ricotta
and the blessings now you have a DD dr.
divinity you have a PhD in religious
studies and people can go to the Dean
show com to hear your conversion sorry
how you accepted Islam now when I opened
the show I said because you accepted
Islam that complete total submission and
surrender acquiring peace by submitting
yourself to turn up he's the one God the
same way of life that was lived by all
the messages of God including geez and I
said you still follow many of the
teachings that Jesus followed yeah my
lion was I telling a lie but you're
Muslim how does this work no well this
is the point and I frequently get into
this discussion with Christians where I
just point out them i say ok you say you
are a Christian fine okay well look
first of all you know as Muslims
everybody is allowed to choose their own
religion okay if you want to be
Christian that's fine if I want to be
Muslim that's my choice you know
everybody everybody has the right to
choose their own religion and we should
live in the spirit of mutual tolerance
of that choice okay however in the
spirit of interfaith dialogue when when
we do get into this discussion what I'd
like to point out is when somebody calls
themselves Christian this means this
means that they consider themselves to
be a follower of
Jesus Christ so we're going to set that
straight so a Christian is supposed to
be someone who is following the
teachings of Jesus Christ well what does
christian mean why don't you find that
take those give us a little bit of a
history lesson just in this word
Christian where it stems from the Hebrew
coming along to the English can you just
briefly what does this word actually
mean the well if you look in the Bible
you follow the excuse me if you look in
the Bible you find the first reference
to Christian it was it was said 42 years
after the time of Jesus admission at
Antioch and it was actually it was
considered to be a derogatory term it
was not a polite term it was like oh you
want to be you want me to be a Christian
you know sort of in this spirit so it
was considered a derogatory term however
with rather typical Christian humility
and I mean that in a good way not a bad
way but in typical Christian humility
they adopted the term and and kept it to
to basically identify their group now we
have to remember that the original
followers of Jesus Christ were Jews they
were Jews they considered themselves
Jews for many generations and they were
proud to be considered Jews it was only
later that the the division between the
Jews who followed the teachings of Jesus
and the Jews who did not follow the
teachings of Jesus this divide became
wide enough that historically they
started to become identified by a
different term originally they started
started to be called Christian Jews by
historians until basically they split to
being called Christians period did Jesus
call himself a Christian no never did he
ever hear this word Christian no
Christianity no and you have to remember
you know the if you look in the Bible
the word Christian is it's only found
three times
and it none of these occurrences
occurred during the lifetime of Jesus
Christ they it did not exist Christian
is found three times Christianity is
found nowhere in the Bible you don't
find it anywhere and it stems of course
from Christ but you have to remember
Jesus Christ was not walking around
saying Christ okay okay what what you
know the word that was you know
translated to be Christ was basically
you know Messiah well you know how the
in Hebrew it was the word for Messiah
and it was translated to 22 Christos in
Greek and then from the Koine Greek and
it was anglicized to Christ but the key
here is we have to remember that that
was not an exclusive term uh-huh if you
look if you look in the Old Testament
you find the this word for Messiah this
word for Christ applied to many
different individuals it was it was
applied 30 x to the Davidic Kings it was
applied six times to the to the high
priest and it was applied twice to the
patriarchs of the Old Testament and so
you had you had a roughly thirty eight
different individuals or 38 different
instances in which other individuals
were identified with the same term
translated to Christ as Jesus Christ so
as Muslims we do not argue with the fact
that Jesus Christ was the Christ do we
believe he was the Messiah but we you
know we believe that he was a man he was
a prophet he was you know he was a
prophet sent by God he brought a
revelation to the people to try to bring
them back from from the deviation that
had crept into their religion but but
but the point is I'm just I'm just
saying to set the record straight Jesus
was a common name okay up until that
time geez
this was a common name and there were
many other individuals who were also
identified by the same term which is
translated to Christ it was he did not
have an exclusive on that term and also
we believe he was the Messiah well I
mean he's identified as one of the
massage what does a massage yeah I mean
there are you know again as Muslims we
believe in a continuity in the chain of
Revelation there there were many
prophets bringing the Word of God too
many different what is this worker gotta
say I mean Messiah actually it means
anoint or weekly wines were anointed
yeah so anybody who was anointed you you
find the root of this word applied to
two nonliving things things that were
things that were anointed yeah we're
identified by the same by the same root
word let me bring us back now okay so
excuse me any individual individual who
was anointed was was identified as a
messiah let's go back to the original
question now okay so we know where this
word stems from jesus never used it he
never knew of this word but today people
call themselves Christians so if you
would ask a Christian they say we're
following Christ but we say we're also
following Christ now when I opened the
show I said you're following Christ you
were trying hard to be a christian right
but you're not a Christian but you're
following Christ what does this mean
well I think this is the point the point
is that Christians believe by you know
the by the name of their religion
themselves to be the followers of Christ
Muslims also believe themselves to be
the followers of Christ and and so you
have these two different religions both
of them saying we follow the teachings
of Jesus Christ the question is who
really is doing it who really is doing
it let's take a break and we right back
with more Hannity show no speech is
better than to do that let's call people
to Allah and to do there were no
speeches better you know
nothing is better than that is it true
that if one person I'm the Allah giving
you an ability to guide someone has a
lot of commission the creator's
permission that is better than
everything in this world but in the
whole world and everything that's in it
in another narration it's better than
the best of wealth but if we really felt
that Eddie would we not be giving out
giving up and this is something that we
encourage all the msas all the dowel
organizations the mustards forget this
we want to prep more we give these to
the nonnamous for free for free for free
we want our brothers I am not afraid to
stand alone if Eliza I am not afraid to
stand alone I am not afraid to stand
alone I am not afraid to stay I am not
afraid to stand alone I am not afraid to
stay back here on the D show with dr.
Lorenz Brown thank you for being on the
show my pleasure it's always a pleasure
to have always now we are talking about
Jesus peace be upon him who is beloved
to our hearts he's one of the mightiest
messages of God we believe no Muslim is
a Muslim with us he believes as she
believes in Jesus so we're not the
Antichrist you know some people would
say like these Muslim are the Antichrist
right of course and they're trying to
project their dislike for the religion
and this is just an excuse that they
come come up with but Islam the Islamic
religion honors Jesus Christ honors his
mother mariam and and we we revere him
for what he was a man a profit somebody
who God chose to convey revelation to
the people now someone make a strong
argument and say hold on hold on that we
as Muslims would you agree follow the
teacher
Jesus more than the Christians do well
okay some make that statement what what
I like to just throw out is for people
just to look at the evidence and come to
their own conclusion so we can say a
talk is cheap but we can back it up with
evidence look let's break it down go
ahead please okay if you're talking with
a Christian it's just kind of natural to
say okay you're a Christian you say
you're a follower of Christ i'm a muslim
i say i'm a follower of christ let's
let's just compare some basic issues and
see who's really doing it okay ask
anybody close their eyes and with their
eyes closed just conjure up an image of
what they conceived Jesus Christ to have
looked like hold on there right now dr.
Brown I'm doing that right now some
people you know they have a frickin
American you know with black eyes and
curly hair but someone else's closings I
they got blonde hair in this church over
here blonde hair blue eye and in another
Church they got the hey-zeus you know
Hispanic looking which one is it well
look guys what church you're at okay and
this is because a lot of people have
turned the reality of Jesus into a
fantasy of Jesus but they all but in
what they own it why would they you know
I'm they have they have tried to sort of
model him to be closer to their heart's
desire ah but my point is that no matter
no matter how a person sees them I still
see a beard on them though that's right
that's right I see a bit like yours kind
of and like yours okay and and like we
see among some Christians but certainly
not the majority very few Christians
wear a beard and very few wear a beard
because they are following the example
of the Prophet they might say then have
razors back then okay but let's move on
because this is a kind of a super okay
okay okay because first of all yeah they
did I mean there were plenty of people
who shaved yeah all right there were
plenty of shade but he had a beard but
the point yeah I mean the point was that
if we if we think about it just from the
very sort of superficial aspect of what
Jesus Christ let's move along from their
beard because let's not get stuck on the
point I mean we know that Jesus Christ I
mean he
a beard okay his his mother mariam if
you conjure up an image of her you
always see her wearing a headscarf okay
walk into any church look at
stained-glass windows look at the
paintings look at the sculptures she's
always covered that's like the Muslim or
a head scarf which is more like what you
encounter with the Muslim headscarf gosh
n gosh you encounter commonly with you
know Christians on this pc okay okay in
the same way picture Jesus Christ
standing during the sermon of the mount
or any other time what do you see him
wearing he's when loose not form fitting
clothing long rope to the wrists to the
ankles maybe tied at the waist by a rope
maybe not but it doesn't show his form
it's a dress of modesty ok and again
where do you see people dressing with
modesty more among the Muslims or among
the Christians many of whom were very
revealing clothing but by you know by
yesteryears standard this is like the
Muslim thobe would you compare to it
like the Muslim thobe or the Muslim even
the muslim abaya for men what they call
the abaya for men and but all I'm saying
is like for example if you took the
people of this time and you transported
them back a hundred years in this
country in America and you walk them
down Main Street USA the Christians many
of the Christians the way they're
addressing now they would be ostracized
by their own people okay go go and look
at go and look at movies that you know
that that were you know filmed about the
people of this time where they portray
them in their realistic clothing you'll
see the woman the women were dressed
again you know long flowing dresses you
know to the risk to their ankles were
head head bonnets and so on and so forth
so this is resembling more the Muslim
now again again we're talking about the
fact that the Muslim embodies the
appearance okay the you know the
appearance of the woman they had scarf
the appearance of the dress this this is
all now kind of you know superficial
aspects of who Jesus was born it was
more please you know now let's go to
let's go to something else let's just go
to how he carried himself what he was
about
yeah he was a man of modesty he was a
man of humility here's a man of quality
when we think of Jesus Christ we think
of somebody who spoke about salvation
who reminded us of religious values we
don't think about somebody who is
constantly dealing with worldly you know
aspects of our existence again it's just
been my experience when you're at a
circle with Muslims you find that the
Muslims are much more commonly talking
about religious issues and sort of
bringing any conversation back to back
to this then then you find in a common
you know just in the sort of common
workplace chatter or whatever among
Christians more yeah okay now this is
not a big point you know and the big
points or more to follow but so you're
saying the Muslims now are more talking
about the spiritual development of the
human being talking about the prophets
about the what God we're over here you
got more material things that you know
the people are focusing on night clubs
dancing hooking up with women things
that Jesus never talked about yeah look
it's just you know most Christians know
that in Christianity most people in
Christianity have made the religion of
pretty much Sunday's only religion yeah
okay and he says this is a 24-7 thing
for him yeah exactly and you know you
find Muslims praying five times a day
making evolution before before prayer
and how do you forget your religion if
you're making evolution before your
prayer praying five times a day getting
you know getting up you know early
morning for the first prayer staying up
you know in the night for the last
prayer and so when how do you forget
your religion your religion cannot
become a sundays only sort of thing when
you're doing it every day did he do this
make evolution did he fall on his face
like we fall on our face and pray okay
now that's annette another step yeah
okay we've talked about appearance
alright we've talked about manners one
of the elements of manners let's look at
something in that that Jesus Christ
actually told us to do all right he told
us to offer the greeting of peace he he
instructed his disciples that when they
meet one another off of the greeting of
case that like we did like we did in the
beginning
is it that's what I'm coming to that
wasn't that's Luke 10 5 okay Luke 10 5
he instructed them but then he he
actually acted out the example four
times in Luke 24 36 in John 20 19 20 21
and 20 26 okay so one time he gave them
a directive and then four times he
actually gave them the example of
offering the greeting of peace and
that's why I was saying in the beginning
we'll come back to this because you find
that practice among the Orthodox Jews
right you find that practice in the Old
Testament you find it in Genesis you
find it numbers you find it in judges
you find it in First Samuel and so there
again there's an example where okay
we've talked about appearance now we've
talked about manners where the Muslims
always greet one another salam alikum
mm-hmm you know peace be upon you
walaikum salam and unto you be peace how
many Christians you find following this
very simple directive mm-hmm you might
say oh this is a small thing come on
this is a little if it's a little thing
why don't you do it mm-hmm you know it's
not like Jesus Christ was telling you to
move mountains yeah he was just saying
offer peace so why don't you do it so
these are some of the details major
minor but it seems like if you're trying
to fit the description of who's
following this these my main major minor
it seems like the Muslims yeah but look
now this is minor I know what everybody
out there is prob about the danger give
us more almost out of time so yeah that
looks something major something that
really can rot you know just rock
somebody's mind practises of worship Tom
Kane first of all religious practices
Jesus Christ was circumcised Paul said
it wasn't necessary in Romans 4 11 Jesus
Christ didn't eat pork according to Old
Testament law Leviticus 11 7 and
Deuteronomy for this is getting good
night the brown ok me some more Jesus
Christ didn't practice usually either
given giving or taking according to the
law Exodus 20 to 25 okay he did not have
any contact with females members of the
opposite sex he didn't shake hands he
didn't touch I'm not talking about
having no relations I'm saying even the
least little contact okay that's that's
those are religious practices you know
and in keeping with the Old Testament
move on to practises of worship he
performed ablution before praying as do
all Orthodox Jews Exodus 4031 he he
prayed in prostration the only
description of Jesus Christ praying in
the Bible was in the Garden of
Gethsemane where he fell on his face in
prayer ok and if you look in the Old
Testament you find that Ezra Joshua
Abraham Moses Aaron they're all
described as praying in prostration so
this was not just his example this was
the example of all the prophecies he
professed 'add for more than a month at
a time and he made pilgrimage now ok who
makes ablution before / for prayer
Muslims the Muslims who prays in
prostration their Muslim five times a
day the Muslims who fasts a month out of
every year the Muslims who makes pit
religious pilgrimage once in their
lifetime required as a tenet of faith
the Muslims is that the end of it no the
most important thing is creed let's hold
off we're going to take a break and
we're going to talk about the most
important thing as we wrap it up here on
the Dean she'll be right back so if you
find yourself your Iman is going down
check yourself there's not a woody to be
worship except Allah alone you got some
serious of music in the car bobbing your
head the fifty cents or no it's common
sense don't do things that can hurt
people Lady Gaga googoo and all that
other nonsense bullying is haraam
backbiting slandering and such
subsystems are smoking stay to 18 inch x
except we'll see what happens to eddie
on the TV show
and we hold it down on a Dean show
Fairly make sure y'all tune back here on
the Dean show with dr. Lorenz Brown and
everything is adding up that it seems
like the Muslims those who have
consciously submitted to the One God
because that's what a Muslim is mm-hmm
seems like we're following Jesus peace
be upon him more than many of the common
day ordinary people today look we've
talked about appearance you talked about
manners we've talked about religious
practices we've talked about practises
of worship but the most important thing
and the message that all prophets really
came to bear was the the message of
Creed in other words you know the truth
of God yeah okay and so we've talked
about these four things the most
important thing is that Jesus Christ
bore the message saying no o Israel the
Lord your God the Lord is one and are
you saying 111 yeah no he's look you
didn't do this this oh you didn't do
this did I didn't do any of this no
making it look it up in mark 1229
matthew 2237 and luke 10 27 okay three
taught three times he bears the message
that God is one this relates back to the
first commandment as you find in Exodus
23 so the bottom line is that Jesus
Christ came saying what saying he was
not sent but to the lost sheep of the
house of Israel lost sheep what does
this mean this means that they have gone
astray from their message okay and what
is the message that he is reminding them
of he is reminding them of their law he
is reminding them of tawheed the oneness
of God pure monotheism pure monotheism
now where are you mysm where does Jesus
Christ ever speak about the Trinity in
the Bible did he ever out of this word
you know the Trinity is nowhere to be
found in the Bible and the biblical
passages that people hold up to support
the Bible cannot be used to support the
excuse me the biblical passages that the
Trinitarians hold up to support the
trinity are actually can
cannot be used to support the trinity
for example the most common one is the
First Epistle of John 5 chapter 5 verses
7 through 8 ok those were written into
the margins of scripture by ascribed
those were not in the original Scripture
all right most most valid Bibles of this
day have have removed that from from the
translation because it's recognized as
invalid and in the same way other
passages which some claim to support the
Trinity can be refuted very very simply
not there nothing eloquent but this is
kind of you know we've jumped away from
the subject the point the point is that
whether you're talking about appearance
manners religious practices practices of
worship or the the creed that Jesus
Christ taught he taught God is one he
taught that he was son of man Jesus
Christ called himself the Son of Man 88
times not the Son of God no no and this
comes down to the a very very critical
separation and that is the separation
between the teachings of Jesus Christ
and the teachings of Paul and the reason
why this is critical it is because
Christianity is founded more upon the
teachings of Paul than upon the teachers
we're going to have to do that in part 2
we have a couple more minutes left now
it sounds like to me and we know that
all the prophets of God they taught
Islam Islam is that call to acquire
peace by submitting your will to the
owner piece the one God and a Muslims
one who does Islam was Jesus and Muslim
all of the profits for Muslims I mean
you said all of them that includes you
so you're saying Jesus as a bold
statement dr. Brown you have to
understand what Muslim means Muslim
means a person of Islam Islam means a
person who submits their will to Allah
okay so yes Islam might have had the
name Islam from the time of Muhammad
peace be upon him but all people of all
time who submitted themselves to the
will of God were Muslims now you wait
was Abraham a human being yes but when
did this word human being come into
existence it wasn't during his lifetime
nice all right I see I'll say it like
that it was gnosis Noah
all human being with a human being that
word didn't exist during their lifetime
I like that okay the word came into
existence later but applies backwards as
well same thing with the word Islam
Islam as a general I mean it's a
description of those who submitted their
wills to Allah and even though that word
may have you know come into existence
with the revelation of the Holy Quran
and the prophethood of Muhammad peace be
upon him it applies to those before him
as well who fulfilled the qualification
one last point we're out of town one
last point you said earlier he was a Jew
now we're saying is a Muslim how do you
put the two together you know be both at
the same time yeah absolutely he was an
Orthodox Jew in the sense that he was
not bringing any new law yeah he was he
was restoring the law of Moses okay so I
mean he was in the lineage of David
Wright and so he fulfilled the
qualifications of being considered a Jew
so that could be like a national
nationality so you could be a Jew whose
a Muslim I said you be a Bosnian Muslim
Serbian Muslim exactly i mean i have not
american muslim russia china russia
Muslim South American Jewish Muslim
whatever yeah okay you know and it
doesn't matter what your ethnicity is
remember I mean remember being a Jew is
basically an ethnicity it was I sang in
that time is Hebrew right you know and
and so you were ethnically a Hebrew but
you could still be I mean gosh you could
be a communist socialist a Democrat or
what but when it comes to religion they
were all of the prophets were Muslim
we're going to take a break and we're
going to have to come back continue this
topic it's a vast topic and we're going
to talk about the comparison which you
said the split between the teachings of
Jesus peace be upon him and Paul in our
next episode sounds good can you do this
God woman Thank You charlie we'll see
you in a few Salaam alaikum and thank
you for tuning in to another episode of
the Dean show we've come to a close but
you got to see it all the evidence adds
up that Jesus peace be upon him who is
beloved to our hearts he was a Muslim he
submitted him self entirety not to
himself but he submitted
off to the one God the creator of the
heavens and earth and he was a messenger
of god and we follow the teachings of
all the messages including the last and
final messages sent to mankind the
Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him tune
in again where we're going to cover the
teachings of Jesus and the teachings of
Paul we're going to continue on with dr.
Lorenz Brown next time we'll see them I
am Not Afraid I am Not Afraid alone I am
Not Afraid so if you find yourself your
Iman is going down check yourself there
is nano with you to be worship except
Allah alone you got some serious of
music in the car bobbing your head the
fifty cents oh no it's common sense
don't do things that can hurt people
Lady Gaga googoo and all that other
nonsense bullying is haraam backbiting
slandering and such subsistence of
smoking state route 18 inch bar except
we'll see what happens to Eddie on the
Dean show
and we hold it down on a game show
barely make sure y'all tuning this will
not happen a Salaam alaikum peace be
with you I may be your host you're
watching the Dean show and the Dean
shows studio we have dr. Lawrence Brown
who you can visit at the Dean show com
you can hear his soul story read a
little bit about them and we're going to
come back and continue talking about
who's following Jesus more are the
Muslims or the Christians and you need
to know that we really want the best for
all of humanity aslam says love all
mankind and that's why we want to talk
about these topics and we want to put
the evidence on the table and we want
you to have an open heart open mind and
decide for yourself decide for yourself
what makes the most sense and we come
back we're going to make sense of it all
with dr. Lawrence Bob Brown here on a
Dean show God woman said type is the
leading one of the beautiful things
about our religion of Islam is the
emphasis on direct ritual and prayer
whom God directly there is no
intermediary the lights will go on after
the party and the party will end it's
very simple and very clear there are no
superstitious rituals no strange
incantations the time is running out we
might not make it to tomorrow and this
is something that we need to think about
that is an interesting thing that the
you know we think when we read the Bible
that we're we're obviously reading the
words that Matthew wrote or that Paul
wrote but the reality is we don't have
the originals of Matthew or Paul's
letters or of any other book of the New
Testament or of the Old Testament what
we have are copies of these books that
were made later in many cases many most
cases many centuries later so we the New
Testament was originally written in
Greek and at present we have something
like 5500 manuscripts in Greek of the
New Testament which is a lot for an
ancient book it's far more than any
other ancient book the problem is most
of these copies are hundreds and
hundreds of years after the originals
and all of them have differences in them
so that the scribes who were copying
these manuscripts changed the text that
they were copying sometimes by accident
sometimes they just made mistakes they
were sleepy or incompetent or whatever
but sometimes it looks like scribes
actually thought the text should say
something other than it did and then
they so they would change the text so
I'll make own piece Bo a few Arkansas oh
my god thank you very much for joining
us dr. Brown now time is short and it's
of the essence people go to the Dean
show calm read a little bit about you
you have a doctors and divinity of a PhD
in religious studies your eye doctor by
profession correct ophthalmologist yep I
have it yeah now you weren't a general
close to being a colonel former u.s.
major now wrong what did you say hua hua
the only general I was ever was i was a
pain in the behind yeah a general pain
in the behind yeah but no i was a major
yeah okay so great so you are someone
who's qualified to talk about this topic
in your previous shows that we've done
you talked about that you were an
atheist actually you were trying very
hard to be a Christian and you ended up
becoming a Muslim the same way of life
that Jesus peace be upon him followed
and we covered this in our last show and
we want to make sense of it all that's
how I opened up the topic we want to
make sense of it all there's a lot of
confusion out there and you said there
was a split in the last show people
again go to to watch that show we did
said there was a split between the true
teachings of Jesus peace be upon him and
now the teachings of Paul right well if
it's more in the practical sense it's a
division between the teachings of Jesus
Christ and the teachings of the church
at this point but what it comes down to
is the teachings of Jesus versus the
teachings of Paul because the foundation
of Christianity at this point is more
upon the teachings of Paul then upon the
teachings of Jesus now a lot of
Christians will not like hearing this a
lot a lot of people out there a lot of
Christians hearing that Christianity is
founded more upon the teachings of Paul
that upon the teachings of Jesus will
object to that but the fact of the
matter is that that is so well
recognized now even even among Christian
scholars that that the Christians
themselves you know many Christians
themselves are speaking of this of this
very fact is there a Bible that has not
only the red letters the black letters
the grey letters and now you can see
like what the words allegedly are that
are closest to being possibly the words
of Jesus not at all said by Jesus might
have been said by G right right well I
think what you're talking about is the
Jesus Seminar the Jesus the Jesus
Seminar has published a book called the
five Gospels and it's basically the four
well-known Gospels Matthew Mark Luke and
John Jesus Seminar who was this well the
Jesus Seminar is a body of Christian
fellows who came together to analyze the
Bible and and by analyzing the Bible
agree upon the authenticity of Jesus's
sayings within the Bible are these
scholars they got together there are
priests ministers pastors their their
religious scholars of a variety of
denomination how many of them got
together a two hundred or two hundred
yeah over you know as memory serves over
time they they have a list of 200
fellows and what do they conclude well
basically in publishing the
the the five Gospels they they published
they published the you know the four
well-known Gospels Matthew Mark Luke and
John and then the Gospel of Thomas and
the the point behind publishing it was
to show which words attributed to Jesus
in the Bible were most likely actually
said by him and which words were not so
they graded them for example if they
felt that the words if they agreed that
the words were most likely stated by
Jesus Christ than it was in red if it
was probable that he stated the words
then there are in pink if it is most
likely that he did not say those words
than it is in gray and if if they felt
that he definitely did not say those
words then it was in black now you would
have to look at there you would have to
look at their scheme for analyzing to
get the exact classifications might be a
little bit you know in a shade of gray
off on their classifications but but
that's basically what it came down to
and when you look through that book what
I can tell you is that you'll just find
an awful lot of black and gray and you
very you know very little of it from
what you would expect is actually in in
red so this is this is just to support
the fact that as most Christians know
there is primantis controversy over what
Jesus Christ actually said actually did
and this is why you find so many books
saying who was the historical Jesus who
was he really what did he really say
what did he really do what people might
say hold on hold on we have Matthew Mark
Luke and John and these were his
companions and they're telling us what
he said they had first-hand accounts
okay well first first of all we have to
remember that Matthew Mark Luke and John
were not necessarily written by his
earthly disciples okay all four of these
Gospels are anonymous you're kidding me
no you know as Muslims we have to tell
the truth no it's really not you can
that bend the truth you can't play with
the truth you got to speak the truth so
what you're saying is a fact or is this
according to dr. Lawrence Brown opinion
no no this is this is well-known going
to go to any seminary school go to any
true Christian scholar read Graham
Stanton read Bart Ehrman all of this is
referenced in my books you can find the
exact quotations but the the bottom line
is that all four of the Gospels are
anonymous documents they are not signed
they are within the framework of the
actual manuscript they are not
attributed to any to any of the
disciples so the the general feeling
among the Scholastic community of this
time is that none of the four Gospels
can be attributed to one of Jesus
Christ's earthly disciples so how do we
come back we come back now as Muslims
and people renault by watching a show
that basically a muslim is one who
submits to the will of god and we say
jesus was a muslim we say that jesus
never taught as you said in the last
show that he never taught taught the
trinity he he never heard the word
Trinity that he never said that he was
going to come to die for the sins of the
world but where are we getting this from
do we see this many in the red letters
that we have well I mean these are
subjects that you know basically they
really deserve to be tackled yeah but
each one is a subject unto itself but
doesn't has come because we put now
Jesus peace be upon him and most people
you know to support this they'll go to
Paul the writings of Paul won't they
well yeah and and this is kind of this
is kind of the point well we we started
out talking about on the last episode we
talked about the fact that the Muslims
emulate the appearance of Jesus Christ
closer than the Christians we're wearing
a beard wearing modest clothing as Jesus
Christ it the muslim women wear a
headscarf ad did as did Mary the mother
of Jesus okay we the practicing Muslims
the practicing Muslims they conduct
themselves with humility with modesty
and they follow the tenets of religious
practice that Jesus Christ talk of
during the greeting of peace okay other
religious practices as we spoke about
circumcision avoiding pork avoiding
usually awarding avoiding contact with
the opposite sex these were all
practices of Jesus Christ that that
Muslims follow better than the example
of the Christians when you come into the
axle of actual worship making ablution
before prayer praying in prostration
fasting but you know a month during the
year in Ramadan making pilgrimage for
religious purposes these were all
practices of Jesus which we find better
exemplified among the Muslims than among
the Christians when it comes to Crede
find Jesus Christ teaching three places
in the Bible that God is one and we
don't find them teaching the Trinity
anywhere now that's a big issue and we
can come back to that let's come back to
that after the break is that okay that's
fun we're going to take a break and be
right back with more over here with
Lawrence brown on the Dean shop I am not
afraid to stand alone it's a lot about
this i am not afraid to stand alone i am
not afraid to stand alone if Eliza
I'm not alone some places it looks like
it's a manipulation of the tax where
where the author wants to change were
the scribe wants to change what the
author said I mean in many cases it may
be that the scribe thought this is what
the offer really meant and so he changed
it but but sometimes the text gets
changed to say just the opposite of what
it originally said and so that's that
connecting me a little bit troubling ya
back here in a dean show with dr.
Lawrence Brown and I want to go back to
Jesus and Paul how does this get
intertwined now how do we get from Jesus
was Paul some apostle was he another
messenger who was Paul okay well this
this is kind of where I was leading to
yeah one we just before the break we
were looking the first episode of the
series we were looking at how the
teachings and the example of Jesus
Christ we find them in many in many
cases better exemplified among the
Muslims than among the Christians and
what were what we're talking about is
how both Christians and Muslims say that
there are followers of Jesus Christ who
is really doing it now when you look at
the teachings of Jesus Christ and you
look at the teachings of Paul one thing
that really stands out is that they're
almost virtual opposites opposite it's
now you would expect them to be the same
it's like the the antithesis of the each
other's teaching you would expect them
to be the saya and the church makes them
sound like they the same but in fact
they're basically opposites opposite
I'll give you an example I mean Jesus
Christ taught Old Testament law yeah all
right he he came bearing the the law of
Moses not trying to change it when he
said you know he said he expressly
stated that he did not come to destroy
the law and the prophets I did not come
but to fulfill and he he you know he
came as what Christians recognize him to
Ben rabbi Jesus right so being rabbi
Jesus I'm what does it mean to be a
rabbi I mean obviously you're following
the Old Testament law so Jesus Christ
bore the Old Testament law to you know
to the people Paul negated it no Paul
basically came up with concept of
justification by faith so on one hand
you had Jesus Christ holding two people
accountable to the law on the other hand
you had Paul saying no more ya can't
canceling it in the same way Jesus
Christ stated that he was an ethnic
prophet he stated do not he say that you
know he did not did not come but to the
lost sheep of the house of Israel yes
negating everybody else yeah I did not
come but to the lost sheep of the house
of Israel Paul said he is a universal
profit for everybody okay now you can't
have it both ways that Jesus Christ said
one thing Paul said another and these
two things cannot you that they are
mutually exclusive you cannot you cannot
blend them Jesus Christ taught prayer to
God I mean the Lord's Prayer you know
when you pray pray in this way right and
he taught prayer to God our Father who
art in heaven he he didn't say to the
people pray to me Jesus Christ taught
prayer to God Paul taught prayer to
Jesus uh-huh Jesus Christ taught divine
unity uh-huh he taught that you know the
Lord our God the God the Lord are good
he taught the Lord our God the Lord is
one ok but is the Pauline theologians
who 300 years later derived the concept
of the Trinity so all I'm saying all I'm
saying is that if you look at the Bible
and see how the teachings of Paul
contradict the teachings of Jesus you
basically are drawn to consider the fact
that you need to decide which one you're
going to follow was it you're going to
follow Jesus Christ yeah a recognized
profit okay where we going to find Paul
a man who never even met Jesus Christ
yeah was not one of his earthly
disciples claimed to
have a conversion through a mystical
experience and then went on to teach
things very contrary to what Jesus
Christ taught so he wasn't an apostle he
wasn't a prophet he wasn't someone
chosen by Jesus or God while speak on
their behalf well what is it apostle I
mean people call him an apostle and they
elevate him they elevate his status
according to how they recognize him but
he was not he was not a disciple he was
not you know he was not an associate
uh-huh Jesus Christ no not at all okay
and did the brother of Jesus James who's
mentioned the Bible and many of the
other companions did they if you read
the Bible take him to task for a lot of
the things that he was teaching oh
definitely and the conflict between the
conflict between the teachings of Paul
and the teachings of Jesus basically
were the foundation of the conflict
between Paul and the true disciples for
example if you read if you read James
right well what is it all about it's all
about I shouldn't say all about but you
know pretty much about this conflict I
mean the you know the chapter faith
without works is dead is the chapter in
which James is is telling Paul that the
the people have assembled and they are
going to pass judgment upon him and so
he's telling him repent you know repent
from the path that you are taking the
negating the Old Testament law and and
and changing the concept of the reality
of Jesus Christ James is telling Jesus I
mean Paul you have to remember Paul put
forward the concept of justification by
faith yeah that you are justified in all
things by faith and not by not by the
law okay you're not you're not held to
the difficulties of the Old Testament
law this in their time was punishable by
death yes this was blasphemy okay and so
James was James was as you said
taking him to task in in the same way
you see conflict with Barnabas you seek
on conflict with Peter you know the
alleged rock upon which the church would
be built and so on so you find find one
disciple I mean just find one disciple
who agreed with Paul who wrapped his arm
around him and said yeah buddy you and
me we're in this together don't it
didn't happen so if you look at if you
look at the Bible and now you look at it
with an open heart open mind and not
what you know your pastor or preachers
telling you and you look at what God is
saying what Jesus is saying what James
his brother is saying you'll find them
in unity but we look at what Paul is
saying you see the exact opposite the
antithesis of their teachings okay so
basically you find Jesus keeping to a
particular teaching you find James and
the disciples exemplifying that or
following that and you find Paul on the
opposite point somewhere will be way off
right left and and and this is out he's
out of the ballpark no this is this is
why you know this is this is why many
scholars have basically categorized
Christianity into the category of those
who are following the teachings of Jesus
those who are basically Pauline
Christian in the modern sense of Pauline
questions which meaning means following
the teachings of Paul it seems like
there has to be another messenger to
come it seems like there's some
confusion and there has to be someone
else coming to make things right was
there any talk of another prophet in the
Old Testament the New Testament that
talks about another prophet who's going
to set things straight this is this
actually okay this might sign sound like
a complex issue but it actually is very
straightforward the Old Testament speaks
of three prophets to follow go and ask
any Jewish rabbi anywhere in the world
how many prophets they are expecting to
follow and they will say three now
there's evidence for this in the New
Testament go to your new testament open
it up you'll find that when John the
Baptist was preaching the Jews sent
their scholars to ask
who he was and they say they accost him
basically and they asked him they say
are you Elijah he says no are you the
Christ he says no are you that profit he
says no how many fingers is that Elijah
Christ that prophet three fingers three
okay and when he denies it then they
actually they restate it they say if you
are not Elijah if you are not the Christ
if you are not that prophet who are you
okay so it was clearly clearly
acknowledging the fact that they were
expecting three prophets know later on
we find Jesus Christ identifying John
the Baptist as Elijah another passage is
in conflict with this but we take it
upon faith that out of these three
prophets John the Baptist was one Jesus
Christ was the second and that leaves a
third who's unaccounted for holy ghost
do they argue this holy ghost no that
has nothing to do nothing to do with it
you can't use as an argument we're not
talking about the Trinity here we're
talking about the expected profits to
follow in the in the continuity of the
chain of Revelation okay profit this is
someone that's coming yeah this is a
human entity okay okay so as I said out
of the three John the Baptist was number
one Jesus Christ was the second one and
this leaves one additional profit this
is why Christianity is identified as a
messianic religion because they are
still waiting for the final prophet to
complete the predictions of their own
Scripture can we tell them the final
prophet the last and final prophet
they're sent to make on when we come
back from the break fine we'll be right
back dr. Brown when outside everything
looks good you see the
hundred-thousand-dollar cars you see a
lot of diamonds you see a lot of females
and they think that this is you know
this is a life this is this is like no
paradise right here
which is my job to go into someone's
heart to change their heart your job is
to topi what the truth is and the alley
over there is while we're sitting here
I'm sitting here constantly paying for
the disease the kill was free
as I studied more and more using my
intelligence as an epidemic abut also
praying about it I became convinced that
the New Testament Gospels were not
written by eyewitnesses or by people who
knew eyewitnesses the first point to
make is the rather obvious one that the
Gospels don't claim to be written by
eyewitnesses they are all anonymous the
titles in your Gospels the Gospel
according to Matthew and so forth were
added by later editor's they were not
put there by the original authors back
here on the Dean show and everything god
willing it it's making sense if you have
an open heart open mind is making sense
you're talking about we left off the
three to come and two are already there
John the Baptist this is yahya in Arabic
yahia and then Jesus Christ he saw a
lady Jolanda that's the second yeah Jews
refuse to accept him as a prophet we
accept that he was one of the mightiest
messengers of God no Muslim is a Muslim
unless he believes in Jesus there's one
last prophet peace be upon him and it is
his teachings everything's got to be set
straight no more confusion can you talk
to us who is this mighty messenger well
I know of course you want me to save
muhammad salallahu alayhi salam and
that's that's of course my answer that's
of course your answer the the bottom
line though is that each person has to
examine the life of Muhammad peace be
upon him examine the revelation that he
brought and based upon that examination
along with prayers to God to guide you
each person has to come to their own
conclusion no we're not pushy I mean
it's it's easy to stand up in front of a
camera and say the final prophet was
Muhammad look it's not that way okay
yeah I mean it's not that way we we are
we are inviting people to examine our
beliefs we are inviting people to to
examine the evidence for themselves and
to come to their own conclusions yeah so
we're going to leave it up to the people
now yeah this is confusion out there and
you know things aren't making sense look
it's not complete confusion I mentioned
before the break that the Old Testament
spoke of three prophets to follow okay
excluding I mean I mean taking away John
the Baptist of Jesus Christ that leaves
one you would expect in the new
testament to find reference to that one
you would expect to find Jesus Christ
speaking of that one in in fact he does
there is a famous passage passage in
which Jesus Christ mentions the fact
that it is good that he will go because
if he does not go he cannot send what is
written in the foundational manuscript
as a lo spero Cletus o que ellos para
Cletus Alice means another Paraclete
house means comforter advocate like a
legal legal advocate a helper what is
para Cletus it doesn't matter why
because elsewhere in the Bible in the
First Epistle of John 21 jesus christ is
identified as para Cletus as a parakeet
okay so now we know what apparently it
is whatever apparently it is Jesus
Christ was one and now he is saying that
after he goes he will send a low sparkly
toes another Paraclete the key word here
is another all right in the Koine Greek
there were two words for another one is
Alice one is heteros heteros meant
another way there are two Alice met
another way there are many a low sparkly
toes meant another of whatever Jesus
Christ was because he was apparently
tall so so another of many like what
Jesus Christ was doesn't that sound more
like the final prophet in the completion
of the chain of revelation of many
prophets so actually even in the New
Testament you find evidence of the final
four total profit as Muslims we believe
that to be Muhammad peace be upon him
and all those who are upon religious
investigations simply need to examine
the evidences for themselves just one
last point just please tell me if
someone just to move this out of their
mind someone says again that's the Holy
Ghost what do you got to say there's I'm
sorry but there's nobody who believes
that that passage nobody among scholars
who believes that that passage refers to
the Holy Ghost because this is not
speaking of the train
okay the passages that they claim to
speak of the Trinity are well known
wasn't the Holy Ghost there at that time
the the holy ghost was pre-existent free
okay I mean if it was it was referenced
before during after the mission of Jesus
Christ so so it but but this is I mean
so I'm just I've heard people say this
that when you mention this some people
say okay this was that the Holy Ghost
that's going to come and be inside of
you and you got to get full of it to
understand it yeah but these I'm sorry
but these are you know I'm sorry to put
it on these terms but these are the
laity these are the people who are just
they're creating an explanation for it
okay these are not the scholars I get a
scholar on your show who says that I
mean I I don't think you'll find it a
valid a valid Christian scholar anywhere
in the world who will claim that these
passages refer to the Holy Ghost because
because these passages you know
explicitly refer to two predicted
profits I'm in the middle of reading
some of your books God had misguided I
love them tell us a little bit about
your books that you got and where people
get ahold of you dr. Brown okay well
there are two websites one is eight
scroll calm just spell it as it sounds
atid HTH scroll ser oll calm the second
website is level truth calm the series
of books that i have written include an
action adventure novel called the eighth
scroll then scholastic religious books
which contain everything that we've been
talking about today on a great deal more
the first one is misguided the second
one is dotted and if you go to the
website level truth com you will find
also articles my conversion story and
and I have other books that are soon to
be published thank you very much may god
almighty allah reward you for being lost
thank you very much thank you for having
thank you and thank you for tuning in to
another episode of the Dean shell thank
you thank you so much and we never want
to hurt anyone
feelings we are sincerely trying to
deliver to what we feel is the truth is
very simple as rational logical all you
have to have is an open heart and open
mind and we talked about the teachings
of Jesus peace be upon him and then
we're following those teachings and we
talked about Islam which simply means to
acquire peace by submitting yourself
entirely to the owner piece the one guy
and that is what all the messengers of
God were on and that's what we're on so
if you want to learn more continue to
tune in to the Dean show you could even
call the 1-800 number on the screen to
get a free copy of the Koran and we'll
see you next time God willing inshallah
until that peace be unto you he created
the universe to him belong the heavens
and live the everliving he is the
furnace he's the unworthy Ethan his
messengers to all his creatures on the
grave danger Oh worshiping other than
Allah there is none greater than the
Creator there is nothing greater than
love
Oh